Not now, not now, not now, I can't run!
Hello, everybody. My name is markiplier
And welcome to Ge.. I'm trying to talk here wind woshers(?)!
Welcome to Gevadan... Gevaudan Ge... Ge... Gevevadan.. Gevadoodian
This is a horror game where you're lost in Wilderness alone (like Marks soul)
Werewolfs, monsters and demons lurk all around you, even in your own home! Even right behind you!
Oh my god! You're the monster!
Ehh whatever. [Read on the screen] "press escape to quit the game. There is no pause for victims. Ever." (Marks face tho)
..."Press right click on the mouse to zoom in. To enjoy the solo experience even more play in the dark while wearing headphones."
Bathed in bLOOD RED LIGHT'S that's explicitly on there
"The beast of Gevaudan. This monster "that had terror spread among humans is responsible for blood baths from June 1764 to June 1767."
"That particular scourge killed between 88 and 124 in France Central region of Gevaudan."
"While some people were thinking about a wild creature Mende Bishop Gabriel Florent de Choiseul-Beaupre"
"sent a call for prayers and repentance."
"That statement would remain known as the 'Bishop of Mende Decree'. All the Priests of the diocese
warned all the believers.  The Bishop tells the story of the beast that was sent on Earth by God to punish the sinners" (what a nice thought)
"Historians also mentioned the possibility that the monster might "have been a serial killer, however no solid proof back-up that theory" (there's never any proof)
"For so long as the beast does not "know you, if you are pure and hold to your faith, you can stare into those two
cursed peals born of the fiery abyss and survive
But as the beast learns your sent and sins it begins its inexorable approach, sliding closer than you dare imagine even in nightmare"
...
....
...  Okay, go to my, ooooooh
Press x to know how how
Okay, so that was a hint on the gameplay that were that were that were, okay?
Why am I here you left me a key, but to what did I get a spooky mansion at the top of the hill?
I'm okay with that so long as I don't get killed by the monster of Gevaudan
I don't like that
32 what does that mean? Hey? Whoa, I fucking me
Who did that where did that where and why?
What does 32 mean?
Whose be wooin who's be wombling? I see you over there, okay? I'm going for it.
Don't like this, I don't like this at all
Why, six, I don't know what that means!
What does six mean, is it the number of the beast?
Heyeeeeeaaaaahhheyyyy
I go...  oh no eyee woo Bigfoot woo wey wo wey wo, no, no, no, I got.. What are you doing?
What are you doing? ehhh, I didn't do that
Yeah, that's right. You get gone. Yeah, I spotted you. Yeah, I saw did you real good you think you didn't saw me?
Where's the lit markers? I got one other here, I know I'm supposed to look for the lit
God, it's certainly not lit out here ah
Is that a lit marker all right, I'm gonna find me my way, five
great
Okay
Again, I don't see the lif, ooh not that way
ah
It's just impossible to see whoa, I jump high like a mad hops
Okay, hey, oh, hey. I don't see anybody
hey
I see you I've got no sin in my heart. Yeah, that's right, you fuck right off. You fuck right off
I don't know where the other marker is I am lost babe in the woods. Oh
It's dark over here. Oh, it's dark on this side of the mountain oh where is it where is it? Where is it?
YEYEYYEY
I don't understand
Fuck this yeah the choir of the damned has started to sing so I'm
assuming that means I'm fucked
What is that, is that a wall?
That's some kind of building that is obviously a constructed wall. Oh are we in the north
Is this game of thrones, not made of ice, but I'll take it
oh boy [Scared]
Hey, hey buddy. No. No hey. No hey
you wibblewobble your way out of here okay? So maybe from the direction that he came from is where I'm supposed to go
I don't know if that's true or not, but that's
You know that's kind of something. Oh, maybe the five means that's Milestone number five
What is this is this when I've been to already, or is this a new one?
Okay, so this is Milestone number six, so I got to find number 32
Maybe I just need to wander into the woods and find it because maybe there might not be a direction to these things
maybe it's just wherever I go could be you never know with that
That might be number five though, is this number five?
Okay, all right. I'm getting it. I'm getting it
Hey, fucking. God damn it stop doing that every single time I turn my back
Are you going to close to go see the evil in my eyes?
Fuck right off. Okay. All right. I got your number. I know what you're doing
I'm gonna follow you back to your home see how you like it
Maybe this key is to your place, and I'm evicting you from your house, and maybe you're not going to be too
happy when I come out and kick you on your ass and
Then kick you in your ass and then kick your ass off, and then kick it all
Around town, I don't know what I am talking about, I am lost in these woods
oh
Yeah, you wiped out sooner than it was before. Where'd you come from where is he oh hey? Hey, bigfoot?
Hey, Givaudan
Man Givaudan dude get get off get off me get off my back
Get off me dick like I'm okay with the whole wandering in the woods horror game
Trope because this is at least a different mechanic than say a slenderman coming up behind me
But this guy I have a funky feeling that he's getting closer and closer and closer and every time he comes by Wanna go
Bro, you want to go, bro. Oh?
oh, oh ahh my balls!
I think that's my intestines spilling out
oh
We're tumbling again. Well. I wasn't supposed to run towards the monster
All right, let's try this again
So there's, ah oh I can zoom in, there is a marker behind me, this is number 4
This doesn't really help me
but maybe if I stare really intensely into the monsters eyes maybe then maybe then it will be so scared of me
of my not sinning nature of my total innocence inside my heart which I have definitely have
Three I don't want to go. I don't want to count down
maybe if I could see something if I get to the top of the Hill
I've got no bearing on the land
He can't see far enough to be able to get any discernible features out of the landscape
So it's just gonna be me and my wits my survival wits ah those are stars, or is that snow?
Can't quite tell I think it's snow all right. He's got to be
Is that ah I think that's yeah, that's a glow okay
All right, all right all right
2? I'm counting down to one I don't want to go to one I need to go to two of is enough
or I need to go to
57 which is like miles away from these ones
Ah, ah that was behind me. Hey buddy. Hey, I see you there. Oh
Staring at you real good. Oh, I must sing oh yeah, okay. Yeah, I better not think any impure thoughts.(BOOOOOOOOOOOOBS) Oh
boy boy that Givaudan Monster sure is sexy
Oh, no, I'm doomed. All right doesn't seem like there's anything over here. There's that wall again
I guess that's just the pen that I'm in to wrassle me in
But I seem to have gone the complete wrong direction. I haven't exactly been counting up the way I need to count
What am I I'm about to hit? I hit the ceiling I hit the ceiling of the world I found the roof mom
I found it. I found the roof hey, you'll never be able to find me in here
Alright, but at least I'm at the highest point. I suppose. That's so weird
The roof of the world they not excite
And not expect anybody to come up here. I see. You look a boo
Peekaboo
Hey, how's it going? Whoa whoa, okay? Found the edge of the world well, what happens if I fall off? Oh?
this was a bad idea I
I found the Edge of the world I guess they didn't expect anybody to go over there, but I sure did who it is I am
What's Gonna happen if I just stay down here forever huh?
and I gonna die
all right let's actually try to follow the trails and use the zooming to be able to guide us where we need to go
this is 32, but why is this one 32 there's another light over there, but I'm gonna try to go over this way and
see like towards the moon because that way just counted to six and
Maybe it's like a circle or something ah I see another one, okay? All right. What number is this going to be?
And why do I need to find a key at a marker?
26 okay, that's not quite what I what is that?
What is that?
Please tell me that's just a tree
What am I looks like a cliff face?
Whoa it is, not the hill. It's a rock. It's a rock. We can ride this bad boy all to our destination. Oh
perfect as they're just a rock jutting out from the
Lands give you this hi
God damn it. I was marveling this rock don't leave me alone. Hey
I got no say hey, whoa that was too close for my comfort. I got no sin in my heart
I'm just looking at this rock. I ain't lusting after this rock okay?
You leave me to my innocence, and then we'll all get along fine
24 the counting is weird on these I think I just got to find them
like Randomly by Happenstance
Is what's this one?
23 okay counting down again, but I've Gotten farther by just following the the
Moon
More rocks. God those are some sexy rocks
I hope the givaudan beast doesn't hear me talking about those rocks that way the curves on those rocks
22 okay, I'm counting down but
then why was
32 right in the middle of this place it must be a bunch of criss crossing paths that
Must be what it be and I just so happened to go the wrong way and find an edge
Or I didn't need to find one
50 wait a minute. Nope just got the 50 somehow
Hey I got th 50 don't get me wrong it ain't 69
You leave me be I see you peeping what do you peep in behind that boosh?
You get over here
got places to be people to see
Markers to lead me to safety If I can get where I need to get then
51 okay, we're counting up, so we might be close
All right, all right all right
Let's get it. Oh, I see you down there
So I'm getting closer that means um maybe not unless it jumps another number again
Which it wants to do not 52 okay? So we're getting closer
there's Aa
Music's changing which is awfully nice like that is the Monster gonna change?
53 four more to go get a key
What it do I don't know
Okay, weird. I know where are you oh I see you see peeking. No. Yeah, that's right
Okay, all right. It gotta be
over the question oh ah it is
Okay, my faith has kept me going and the woods are dying over here. Which is a good sign
I guess before getting closer, huh, let's just be that way, right?
It would be down this valley
It seems like something that they would be leading me into the denser ahh the denser forests lead me to my victory
All right, 57 just do more to go don't kill me. Oh, I think I see something over there nope
I lied as it's a trick of the mind. I'll just follow the woods
Simply the same thing yeah
Two more I don't know what am I fine? It is number 57, but I'm sure I'm excited for it
56, 57 must be
Continuing down this way, right?
Hey, where were you where I see in there, all right
I'd be peepin ya  no no no no no no no no no no no no no no I can't run!
Fuck you, I was right there
my heas has been cut off and I'm rolling, damn it unfortunately, I'm actually all out of time
I thought I was gonna find it right then and there, I'm out of time today. I got to go ah
Fuck all right. I might pick this up again just to see what the mystery is or I don't know
Maybe like slap it on to another video just so I can see because I'm curious
I want to know the game is good few flaws here and there
But I want to know why am I going for this key so either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching sorry I'm out of time, but I will try to get this in another video
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video
Bye bye!
This was a pain in the ass to type!